the youngster here's vard dropping it back
off gadoo now vard with a shot saved by old
Mark coming around with theard he STS his first
National Hockey League [Applause] goal he takes
a shot not from a great angle but look at the
net fromont Presence by allall and lzard gets
his first of his National Hockey League
career and there's that quickness push
down the wall back to the L Faber a shot he
scores BR Faber with The Season's first goal
and Minesota leads Mavis trying to protect the
puck out High left it on the blue line and now
Anaheim with numbers down low Lov sets it up
and mov with the [Music] finish the first NHL
goal for pav mov tapen for cadri Phillips Chris
crosses through center with Milano Sunny On The
Go Milano CRA passes a beauty score Matthew
Phillips burns the hand that youed defeat
him Jamie Ben couldn't further it along
and now possible two onone Terry gets
on his horse across the line with Carlson
Carlson SC first NHL goal for the second
overall pick byes they play on and a
penalty will be called they score Ty
Ki gets a beautiful pass from M veneers the
Kracken by three Deals it back to the point
less than 30 seconds left on the power play
cross ice pass scores the go a hit goal the
first in the National Hockey League
yes gets that puck in one motion he
snaps it and yeah long time waiting for
that denado centering the fourth line of
forwards for the haxy out there to begin
this power play and here's Conor Bard he
[Applause] scores a goal in the home opener for
Conor Bard welcome to Chicago holy jumping what
a shot with his goal tonight has half
of them he's got five Le pass outside
lafier shoots sp there is his first NHL
goal Alex larier and the game is tied at
one see the goal but everything else aside
good shots oh here we go B Ro's got a man
open Evangelista with a new stick coming
in Evangelista score yes sir watch this
shape right here Blackwood was going to the
other side look at that fate pulls it back
uses his Edge Ian mitell picks it up sends in
Kiki centering pass pakra has his first NHL
goal good Vision by geeky on the backhand
feed good one time forehand shot by the
kid JJ Moser leading the rush over the line it
goes kolie is in kie Stars Logan [__] and a
beauty first in the National Hockey League
for 92 look at the love the kids getting
stick that in your pipe and smoke it cadri t
shoots defle down Cherry scores Conor Cherry
in his first HL game gets a ball that makes
it one nothing the calvary being Jeff Skinner
PA Thompson centering pass
score 2-1 Buffalo just after the goal was
waved off on the review brro
scores the first of his headl
career for sure he was got to shoot that Bobby
bre first NHL goal now zis it rolls in front of
the net taken back and oh Terry is robbed and
then Carlson scores the penalty had expired
it looked like Anaheim was going to score three
times marches down that right wing fires jackets
block it and the way to go is fantilli down the
left wing and across the line Adam Filly scores
what a shot what a goal Columbus two and a hve
one backto back games for the rookie and goals
at each it's 2-1 turns and fires and it's snared
by blassic and now Felino coner Bard scores and
the Hawks have tied in the first period lethal
R shot put it on his tape a little bit of time
he rolled that from the heel to the toe and
thanks for coming High over the glove and the
game is tied at two k as you did see Samy faga
watch out out for his shot here he is fires he
scored and we talked about Figo shot he can
absolutely rip it with a bit of room Slap
Shot save rebound play back to Len high
slot lenol passing scored first NHL goal
Matt Coronado on the power play fles take
a one- nothing lead in Pittsburgh round the
board kept in by gon D TR and coie he scores
will coie his first NHL goal and the Rangers
have cut Columbus's lead to 4-2 the game and
set the stage for the shap the or late game
heroics Michael Lano d and g f SCS AO has
the feed and pavor Fs first to the air and
the golden knights with the lead a minute
35 H to Lindholm de brus back with snap
shot and padra has his [Applause] second and
chck to the head of Joseph in comes Greg his
man calls Greg and shoots [Music] SC sh fell
gre's head Advantage jams the Puck out of the
corner Middleton to Hartman centers they score
Marco Russy on the deflection and Minnesota ties
it kuk dropped it back aosu had it deflect off
Ellen Jones in deep centers Gutman scores Cole
Gutman has tied it at two with nine 55 to go back
moves it across cut off by Duman leate pass break
in TI cier he scor hey hey what do you say Tai
Kier 55.7 seconds left in the second period 3
to one Seattle they'll make a pat save there Ro
dishing L turns looks up high top of the circle
shot scores Ur check his first National Hockey
League goal his first NHL Point tied the most
goals he'd allowed in a game in his career outen
into the offensive end here's corac with a r shot
score that in a body on the way to the net and
Kaden corac is first in the NHL to tie the game
create something Fourth Man second wave lefair
a ahead for dupai and on go a chance kicked out
rebound scar lefair [Applause] here he bangs
home the rebound chance for the game's first
goal ja Hughes takes it down low minute 15 left on
the power play Luke drives and [Applause] scores
his first goal this year his first NHL power play
goal devils are ahead you don't to look too deep
into some of these CLS but Merill retreating
right there here's another chance and Rossy
scores Marco Rossi stretches his scoring
streak to three games and has his third
NHL goal Minnesota's on the board first 45
seeds here Le last year the regular season
he's looked good nice scores Matthew dies has
his first ever regular season goal and the leaps
are within one and now he can settle down after
that big save walking out of the corner back Ed
there by Johnson little Tic Tac to scored
his first National Hockey League goal for
ronov get that puck Johnson jackets will scoop
it up and baronov who went immediately to the
net you talked about it earlier he was there
and he was able to tip it home and the jackets
have tied it up these guys trust these guys
to get going watch's out for a fary now he's
got Brink again Brink scored his first NHL
goal earlier and there's the [Music] second
and again as connecting stepped into the one
from the slot now a chance for an empty n here
byro's got the empty net he's got one he's going
to get two Brandon vro welcome back back blast
gets across to keep it in Rick wide pass and chck
room will get there as well here's zaru has a body
in front they score tipped in Ridley Greg the
power play works for ottaa on the board first do
the Hawks and the off season aggravated a shoulder
injury on Saturday night here's Patra in a load he
scores Matt ptra pots another his third
in his last two games and it's two nothing
Bruin here's Bal out top his rot score Brandon
paal snaps it home is first in the NHL it's for
one Vegas stopped his rush trouba trying to
keep it alive D'Angelo swept it away trouba
and after for it again cers and he score
well cruy great play by Jacob tra to set
him up two to one Rangers holding quickly was
angled but Doby gets it back here's Max Doby
is get from KN SC Matthew ni double dips and
the game is tied with the pass how about that
pick up by n gets down on one knee theof
into the devil Zone ball toward the line
knocked out of the air by Baldi rhin back
to Baldi a shot save van check rebound Roxy
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] scores
the gamewinner in overtime against
Vegas on Friday to start this road trip
Kevin kinsky now pass across Berard
scores oh you got to love that combination
Blackhawks fans cor chiny to Bard and the lamp
is lit finds Bard so he's on the right hand side
head up all the way and he put this right on the
tape and this is just a brilliant reception of the
pass right there gets it to Johnson Johnson drops
it for tck check ly for the other way go the f f
f trying to Spring Brink he does bring and goal he
scores Bobby Brak and the Flyers are back up
by four it's five to one intercepted here posil
over to Dylan du things coming in Du shot
right patched up and it's in the NIT they
score the Calgary Flames have answered
back and that is Martin popal's first
career National Hockey League goal
left for the room and never returned
centering pass in front right idea Maro
could not get a stick on it though quick
shot scores from up high it looks like
bonov gets his stick on it great look
at that for those guys smile we're going
to get used to that smile from Bron a one
timer Patra closes and wow phly whoo his
athletic supporter is in the rafters oh
what a goal scorers move right there H
right on rebound shovel on then on the
backhand by Carlson got his own rebound back Terry
scor Carlson in front along with
Jones there here's the shot yeah
it's off the shaft of the Stick of
Leo Carlson should have definitely
been a penalty you're not allowed to
to kick any broken sticks up [Applause]
for there was basically no space but he was
able to get that puck out to him and Marco
Rossi looked to me like he knocked that one
out of the air and caught Jonathan Quick a
little surprised by that Kev and W Stena took
his eye off the puck and guess who Conor Bard
scores yes sir number five for Conor
and it's four [Applause] [Music] nothing